bonjour à tous c'est un grand plaisir de
pouvoir m'adresser à vous pendant le
congrès du modem votre congrès et je
remercie tout particulièrement françois
qui est présent ici à paris de son
invitation
c'est un grand plaisir et une émotion
particulière parce que évidemment vous
l'imaginez bien nous avons beaucoup
pensé à vous cette semaine et
aujourd'hui tout particulièrement avec
la disparition du président valéry
giscard d'estaing
c'est évidemment un événement pour notre
pays avec ce président qui a su réformer
notre pays le transforme et l'engagé
dans la modernité et dont vous avez été
des soutiens des compagnons de route
aujourd'hui les héritiers ses idées qui
ont façonné l'udf puis aujourd'hui le
modem ses idées de liberté
ces libertés ses idées de d'humanisme
ses idées européennes nous agir nous les
partageons en très grande majorité
nous sommes très proches de vous à
travers ces idées nous nous disons
libéraux pro-européens humaniste et
réformateurs c'est dire si la proximité
est importante mais au-delà de ces idées
au delà de ce partage finalement aussi
d'une partie de l'héritage
nous sommes en proximité dans notre
éthique d'engagement c'était éthique
d'engagement qui fait que certes nous
défendons nos idées avec détermination
avec pugnacité sans jamais les laisser
dans notre poche sans jamais évidemment
les trahir en s'inscrivant dans un
parcours militant en parcours d'élu dans
un parti mais aussi avec cette
détermination à l'eau moment venu savoir
parfois dépassés simplement
l'appartenance partisane au service de
quelque chose qui nous dépasse au
service de quelque chose de plus grand
l'intérêt général le service de sa ville
de son département de sa région
bien sûr du pays
ou de l'europe 7 et type d'engagement
qui manque parfois si souvent à notre
pays et que françois mon cher françois
tu as toujours porté très haut et fort
et démontrer à quel point tu en faisais
une éthique toi dans ton parcours
politique et cette éthique d'engagement
ses idées ce qui fait que nous sommes
très proches
c'est aussi ce qui a fait que nous avons
un moment donné avec mes amis d'agir
pris la décision de quitter les
républicains parce que nous ne voulions
pas laisser la droite à la frange la
plus conservatrice la plus souverainiste
la plus eurosceptique et donc nous
voulions continuer de porter les idées
d'une droite républicaine telle qu'elle
avait imaginé par cette perf en date
heure au moment de la création de l'ump
et puis parce que aussi nous voulions
absolument saisir la main tendue par le
président de la république le président
mâcon qui venait d'être élu pour refaire
de ce quinquennat
non pas un échec mais une réussite pour
la france ne pas s'opposer d'une façon
stérile alors que beaucoup des deals
d'idées nous les partageons mais au
contraire de pouvoir participer à notre
niveau
chacun à sa place mais avec cette
détermination de contribuer à l'intérêt
général
en faisant de ce quinquennat une
réussite pour la france et aujourd'hui
on est très fier très fier et très
heureux d'être à vos côtés dans cette
majorité avec la république en marche
avec vos modems et avec mes amis d'agir
pour faire de ce quinquennat
une réussite pour la france alors ça se
passe au sein du gouvernement à côté
derrière le premier ministre jean castex
avec mes amis du gouvernement que je
salue que j'embrasse jacqueline marque
geneviève nathalie et sarah ça se passe
à l'assemblée nationale aux côtés
d'olivier bêche le président de notre
groupe et on travaille toujours très
fructueux avec patrick mignola que je
salue aussi j'ai vu tout à l'heure à
l'image et tous les députés du groupe
modem
bien sûr au sénat vous savez que nous
avons avec le groupe des indépendants
des sénateurs agir au sénat sous la
houlette du merveilleux et talentueux
claude malhuret et puis sur le terrain
où vous militants élus du modem
travailler avec nos élus et nos
militants d' agir au service encore une
fois de l'intérêt de ces territoires
nous avons su démontrer aux européennes
que nous étions capables de nous
rassembler avec la république en marche
et les autres partenaires de renaissance
nous démons nous avons su démontrer dans
un certain nombre de villes
même si nous avons j'espère les uns et
les autres tirer certains enseignements
de ces élections municipales démontré
que nous pouvions nous rassembler j'ai
des exemples dans nombreux départements
militants modem et agir se sont
rassemblés et puis nous allons devoir le
faire pour les prochaines élections
les départementales et régionales la
stratégie qui est aujourd'hui la note de
travailler avec une réflexion une
préparation de la majorité avec la
république en main avec vous et avec nos
amis d'agir pour essayer de département
par département région par région
faire les bons choix ça va pas être
simple étant donné évidemment que ce
sont des élections intermédiaires étant
donné qu'il y a des histoires locales
différentes et des personnalités aussi à
la tête des régions qui sont parfois
différentes mais nous devons toujours
avoir en tête ce qui est un adn commun
d'avoir en tête de satisfaire non
seulement est de présenter satisfaire un
projet fort pour la région le
département mais aussi s'assurer que in
fine et l'intérêt général du département
ou de la région sera pris en compte dans
notre décision stratégique de
rassemblement qui devra être un
rassemblement de la majorité mais aussi
de rassemblement plus large parce que
dans une élection locale départementale
ou régionale
il faut penser surtout avec un mode de
scrutin comme celui-là a rassemblé plus
large et enfin viendra ce moment très
important pour notre pays qui est le
grand rendez-vous de 2022 qui est déjà
quasiment demain
ce grand rendez vous il nous faudra être
à l'auteur à nouveau de nos
responsabilités pour permettre aux prêts
en arrêt public de gagner ces élections
et de faire un deuxième mandat il est
aujourd'hui
un président avec un leadership reconnu
dans le monde entier
moi qui suis aujourd'hui au ministère de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères je
le mesure tous les jours il a eut
démontré avec courage détermination
résilience qu'il était à la hauteur de
la fonction et nous avons donc besoin de
lui
plus que jamais avec l'expérience qui
sera la sienne en 2022 pour relever les
défis de la france et du monde et nous
en aurons besoin aussi pour continuer
les politiques engagées depuis 2017
nous avons trop souffert dans notre pays
des changements de majorité qui les unes
après les autres les uns après les
autres ont contribué à affaiblir les
politiques qui doivent ses politiques
publiques est mené dans le temps long je
le vois bien dans le secteur que je
lâche ans aujourd'hui dont j'ai la
chance aujourd'hui de m'occuper le
secteur du commerce extérieur
je vais vous donner un chiffre ou de
plusieurs chiffres le déficit commercial
de la france aujourd'hui ses 60
milliards d'euros en 2020
malheureusement avec la crise on devrait
arriver à peu près 80 milliards d'euros
quand les italiens sont à + 53 milliards
d'euros et les allemands plus de 125
milliards d'euros c'est le résultat de
plusieurs éléments 1 c'est le résultat
du manque d'entreprises qui s'exporte
dans notre pays nous avons 130 mille
entreprises exportatrices quand les
italiens en ont deux cent vingt mille et
les allemands 300000 nous menons depuis
2018 et je continue avec détermination à
mener cette politique là une politique
qui vise à rassembler les acteurs de
l'exportation bpi france business france
les chambres de commerce et d'industrie
toutes les fédérations professionnelles
et syndicats professionnels pour pousser
toujours plus de pme de teillé à
l'international c'est la clé pour
pouvoir exporter davantage
je fais en sorte de je fais en sorte
aussi de avec les différentes
partenaires du commerce extérieur de
faire en sorte que nous ayons davantage
de stratégie industrielle
avec évidemment le ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
relancer ses équipes avec tous les
ministres qui sont de près ou de loin
concerné par ce commerce extérieur mais
avec la détermination de définir une
vraie stratégie sur le long terme
ça nous a manqué depuis tant d'années et
c'est françois encore une fois toi qui
avait raison avant les autres la
nécessité de penser loin sur le long
terme avec la création de ce haut
commissariat au plan nous avons besoin
collectivement de définir des stratégies
comme ont su les faire le chiffre des
chinois pour que notre industrie puisse
relever les défis de demain alors nous
avons réussi avec le plan de relance a
les mesures qui sont prises de
transformation du pays depuis 2010 est
de préparer notre industrie mais il
faudra mener ce temps là sur le ce
travail-là sur le temps long c'est
absolument indispensable et nous devrons
continuer à transformer le pays comme
c'est fait depuis 2010 est au service de
la compétitivité de nos entreprises et
enfin il faudra travailler au niveau
européen pour de doter d'outils beaucoup
plus forts de défense de nos entreprises
vis-à-vis des chinois vis-à-vis des
américains et c'est ce travail que nous
menons au quotidien
voilà le travail qui nous reste devant
nous je suis encore une fois très fier
avec toutes mes amies d'agir de pouvoir
avec vous conduire les destinées du pays
participer à cette oeuvre de
transformation de conduire je l'espère
d'un grand nombre de régions et de
départements demain est de faire en
sorte que nous puissions offrir une
victoire représente la république car
c'est l'intérêt du pays
je vous remercie et vous ne permettrait
enfin de mon intervention de félicité
françois pour sa réélection alors
c'était attendu cher françois
mais c'est toujours assez remarquable
ces signifiants
parce qu'en politique rien n'est jamais
inscrit à l'avance donc bravo bravo à
toi bravo à toute l'équipe et j'embrasse
marielle bonne fin de congrès